[Music]
I'm Grant Imahara along with wired brand
lab and Mouser I'm traveling the world
exploring the ways people and companies
are using innovative technologies and
shaping Smarter Cities I'm here in Tokyo
there's a lot of people here which means
there's a lot of mouths to feed that
represents a challenge for the city of
the future
tokyo-based Mirai and singing the idea
of a traditional farm and literally turn
it on its side they control all the
conditions here so you don't have to
have perfect soil or perfect weather or
even sunlight this approach has the
potential to overcome farming challenges
like yearly weather patterns changing
climate as well as the quality and
availability of land what are some
advantages that the Mirai vertical farm
has over a traditional farm Pocono
quinoa no Universal aah
no unity gustaba so Portugal's Connect
is now so no toto you can you pocket
co-co-co co-co-co co-co-co co-co-co side
i no point to another communist which
heavy Atari no shukaku you say and you
know
Geronimo go to parameter R cause your
bike on a hakuhodo Imus the same ayat of
Allah day caucus I worked a sigh
ridiculously how can vertical farming
make things better for anyone out there
but Japan has a possibility to be
installed over almost everywhere in any
kind of size with any kind of producing
crops Missoni Tasha gotta know yo
tyranny telugu lavanya show to the
scores over me regards to table aside
quinoa
Tokyo more muscley chocolate students
yes Cara
conquer beautifully tokuda my regime you
know collocation acting in OS toxic
sarony a continuous acid Tituba
Michigan mistletoe you know on Delancey
of consciousness I do stay muscle
so Google's fedora hobo music's the
serega Johnson stamina Kaiser stated
again on a thorough June console cacao
unanimous por la ok night Narayana
business the environment is getting
unstable and the number of people on the
earth is getting bigger and bigger there
are many ways for Jack efficient
agriculture but one of the solutions is
the particle form when you think about
the city of the future probably gonna
see a lot more of these types of farms
what Mirai is doing with vertical
farming is made possible by components
from all over the world it's just
another example of how Mauser suppliers
like analog devices Intel microchip
technology and molex are helping shape
the future of smart cities next I'm
heading to Los Angeles to peek at the
future of city building